[MUSIC PLAYING]
KRISTIE MANN: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to our talk
on persistent memory.
Now I'm going to ask
a question, and I
want to see a lot
of raised hands,
or you're going to
hurt my feelings.
I love this guy.
All right.
So how many of you remember
a world before the cloud
and before data?
Thank you.
All right.
So our world is changing.
And I'm going to tell you
a personal experience going
to the Grand Canyon with my
brother, father, mother--
summer vacation when
I was growing up.
And we went to go
to the Grand Canyon.
And dad says, hey, kids,
let's get in the station wagon
with the wood paneled sides.
And let's go get a triptych.
How many of you know
what a triptych is?
Uh oh.
Now I'm really old.
OK, so you would go to AAA.
They would print out the route
that you were going to go.
And they would help you map
along the way what you wanted
to stop at, what
was along the way,
and you'd get this book of
maps for the whole trip.
We thought that was so cool.
And that's what we were doing.
In that world, we
were not generating
mountains, and mountains,
and mountains of data
like we are today.
Fast forward to MapQuest.
I thought that was the best
thing since sliced bread,
right?
I could print out on demand
where I wanted to go.
So I was starting
to consume data,
but I was just at the
tip of the iceberg.
And then we had turn
by turn directions.
For those of you that are
directionally challenged,
that was life changing.
I don't go anywhere
without my phone.
Add to that now the
world of ways, where
we're crowdsourcing the data.
We're actually generating
data as we drive
for the rest of the world.
You guys know where I'm
going with this story.
So let's look at
the amount of data
that's being produced as we
speak, in today's day and age.
I quote these
numbers over and over
again because they give them
to me in a slide to quote.
But let's think about what
we're doing with that data.
There's zettabytes of data
that businesses are producing,
but we're not able to
take advantage of it
because it's just
sitting in repositories,
and it's a liability
rather than an asset.
We believe we have
a technology that
can help us on the
journey to changing that
so that when we reach
175 zettabytes in 2025,
the world is able to process
every inch of that data,
make smarter decisions,
and do more with that data.
So I'm going to talk to you
about the most loved memory
storage hierarchy.
We've all seen it
a million times.
I've had it drawn
this way in particular
because we tend to think
of it as a continuum.
But it's not really a continuum.
There's big gaps in
performance and in cost
as you jump between
DRAM and storage
and which is the fast
storage, then down to tape
and hard drive.
And for 50 years, the
architects of the world
have had to adjust the
way that they programmed
to minimize their memory usage.
Because it's very expensive,
and the capacity is limited.
We also see that DRAM isn't
scaling at the same rate
that our data is.
And so what if we could have
this amazing technology where
we could have double,
triple the capacity,
give up very little
of the performance,
and do it in an affordable way?
That seems like a
dream come true.
And today, I'm here to announce
we just went live last week.
This is a half a
terabyte in my hand.
Whoever thought we
would see that day?
And this is now broadly
available with Intel's Xeon
Cascade Lake CPUs.
And we believe that we're
going to be changing
the world with this technology.
We're just beginning
on the journey.
So I'll tell you a
little bit about it.
It comes in modules 128,
256, and 512 gigabyte.
To help level set 32
gigabytes to maybe 64
is kind of a sweet
spot for today,
so it's much higher capacity.
It also has the ability to
be spoken to in either memory
language or storage language.
So it's byte addressable and
bit addressable in 4k blocks.
It has multiple modes.
We have a memory mode
and an app direct mode.
And I'll talk to
you a little bit
about that because I know
several of you in the room
are developers, and you want to
know what this means for you.
And it's natively persistent.
So the data is at
rest in the CPU block.
That changes the way we
think about our data.
It's also highly secure.
We have hardware encryption.
It fits in DDR4 DIMM slots,
and it's also physically
the same form factor.
So it's not terribly intrusive
to the system designs
that we have today.
So let me touch a
little bit on the modes.
We have an app direct mode.
And that just basically
means that the application
is able to smartly place
the data where it belongs.
If it's hot data that's being
used on a regular basis,
it can reside in the DRAM.
If it's colder data
or cooler data,
it can reside in
either the Apache--
I just started to call
it by its code name--
in the Intel Optane
DC persistent memory
or in storage.
And we have a whole
range of ISV partners
that are helping to
redefine and redevelop
the architectures
of their software
to take advantage of
this new capability.
The application
and the OS actually
see two separate
distinct pools of memory.
And that's what is
encompassed in the app direct.
When you look at memory
mode, we have this mode
for applications
that haven't yet
been optimized to take
advantage of the capability.
And so what we like
to say is that it's
fairly easy to get in
and try the technology.
The application and the OS
sees a single pool of memory
like it always does.
And it doesn't realize
that the DRAM that's
installed with the Optane
DC persistent memory
is actually being used as a
cache to help speed things up.
So it's fairly transparent.
You don't always get the maximum
benefit of the technology
when you're in memory mode.
To get that best
performance you want
to be app direct optimized.
But this allows you to get
in and try the technology
and still take advantage of the
capacity and the affordability
that the product brings.
So when you look at the new
way that we envision the memory
storage hierarchy, you can
see that we put the Optane DC
persistent memory right
in that large gap that
existed between the
storage and the memory.
We also have lots
of improvements
that Intel's been making
in our 3D NAND SSDs.
And this same media is available
in a solid state drive form
factor as well.
And so we're working on
really giving the architects
and software developers
of the future
that full range of
products to design around.
All right.
So when I'm talking to
people about this technology,
sometimes it takes
a little while
to grasp what it
means when you move
between these different
types and tiers of memory
and storage.
So we like to think
about it in terms of what
problem are we trying to solve.
If you've ever said to yourself,
wow, DRAM is so expensive.
I wish I could afford to
put more data in memory,
but I just can't, then this has
the ability to help save money
when you pair it with DRAM.
You also have the ability
to improve your memory
to core ratios.
You can do more with
existing infrastructure.
And then in the app direct
mode that we talked about,
if the solution is
optimized, you also
have the ability to really
help break the performance
barriers that you were seeing
if your application was memory
limited.
And you can see a
lot more performance.
So I have one final slide.
I want to talk to you
about the partners
that we're working with in
the cloud to provide ecosystem
support for this technology.
Yes, I said it.
Intel is innovating
on the software side.
It's really important that
we-- because we need the ISV
partners to be on board,
we need the service
providers to be on board, and
the OEMs have to be on board.
You need all of those
elements for the solution.
We've been working over
a decade to make sure
that we have all of the
pieces pulled together
for this solution.
And these are some
of the key partners
that we've been working with
over the last several years.
You hear us talk a
lot about SAP Hana.
But we have a lot
more beyond that.
We're working with SAS, all
of the ISV and OSV providers,
as well as our partners
here at Google.
So I'm going to bring
up on stage today next--
and I thank you
guys for your time.
Shideh is going to
talk to you about what
Google is doing with us.
SHIDEH SHAHIDI: Thank you.
Thanks, Kristie.
So I hope you guys can hear me
because I can't hear myself.
I hope I can keep your attention
while the band is playing back
there.
So Kristie talked about
the memory technology
and the landscape in general.
I am hoping to
let you know about
how this technology is actually
realizing in Google Cloud,
and how you can go
and use it, and what
are the different use cases that
we've been experimenting with.
So we partnered with
Google around two years ago
on this technology to
bringing it to Google Cloud.
And they announced it
back in March of last--
I'm sorry, the
November of last year.
That was actually a few months
before our own product line.
So there went a lot of work from
both sides, engineering work,
into bringing this
product into market.
So they were the first
cloud service provider
to bring this into market.
If you look at what this
technology translates
to in terms of the VMs that
you have in Google Cloud,
basically, this is providing
more memory for you.
If you look at the
VMs that are enabled
by this Optane memory versus
the previous generation,
there's actually 4x more memory
per VM that this enables.
So more memory that is
faster than SSD that's
sitting closer to your compute.
And it's basically
persistent, right?
So that's just putting
all of that together,
it creates a lot of
different use cases
that are interesting to enable.
Some of the use cases use the
persistence of the memory.
Some don't.
So if I went to talk about
some of the use cases
that we've been exploring,
one of the main ones
is basically because you
have this memory that's
per VM that's
close to your core,
you can actually use
this as some sort
of a cache for your I/O
intensive applications, right?
So this would prevent you
from going back and forth
between the IO
and the IO latency
is going to be prevented.
So that's one of the use cases.
We've actually done
some experimenting
with that use case.
We've done some Spark
SQL analysis inside GCB,
and we've seen about 4x better
performance for our large data
sets.
Another use case that
we kind of explored
was looking at the persistency
of the memory, right?
So the persistency
of the memory allows
you to basically keep some of
the key values for your data
inside this memory.
So when your VM
is restarting, you
would basically have the
data available close to you
so you wouldn't have to go
through the whole loading
of the data.
So basically, that translates
to faster restart times.
We've also looked
into that application
for different in
memory databases.
And for one of the ISVs that
we've actually worked with,
we've seen the load times
going from somewhere a little
more than 20 minutes to
less than 20 seconds.
So that's the kind of
improvements that we've seen.
And then the last thing
that we've kind of explored
in this environment is basically
the last value proposition,
is looking at the memory
size and how you can condense
more instances into one VM.
So basically,
different residents.
So if you have a database
with multiple instances,
you can compute-- you can
basically put everything
into one single VM.
And especially if it's
not very core intensive,
if it's more memory
intensive, you
can potentially have
some cost saving there
because you're not
paying for all the VMs
that you would normally if you
were taking that much memory.
So those kind of
summarize the value
propositions inside this
in the card environment.
Now, I'm going to tell you a
little bit about what actually
shapes our VMs these
are offered in.
So these memes are both--
if you can see, there are
two different VM shapes
that this memory is offered in.
The first VM is a
smaller VM shape.
It offers 96 vCPUs.
It has 624 gigabytes
of DRAM, which
is tied with 3.6 terabytes
of Optane memory.
There is this bigger
size VM that actually
has 1.2 terabytes of DRAM.
It ties back with 5.5
terabytes of Optane memory.
And the totals of
the memories, you
can see 3.6 terabytes
and 6.7 terabytes.
Both of these are running on two
socket Intel Xeon processors,
the next generation, basically.
This is the Cascade
Lake codename.
And they're both
single tenant today,
the way they're offered,
meaning if you get the instance,
you basically have control
over the whole Optane
memory and the whole vCPUs.
The two instances are
both in app direct mode.
Kristie talked about app
direct mode, I think.
Andy's going to talk more
about the details of how
to program for app direct mode.
But basically, at very high
level, what app direct mode is,
is it's the mode
where you can take
advantage of the
persistence of the memory.
So you have the address space
of the Optane separate from
the address space of the DRAM.
And you can get--
basically, the application
can get to choose
where to write what.
So you can have an
architecture where
you would store your hot data
into DRAM versus your cold data
into Apache Pass.
I said it.
Code word, so Intel Optane.
So basically, these VMs are
enabled in app direct mode.
And we've been working
with different partners
to enable their
application for this mode.
And we'll get into some
of the details of what
we've been doing.
Just a quick note on how you
can get access to these VMs--
so that link on top,
this is basically
where you can request access
for an alpha instance.
So these offerings are
in alpha right now.
Google is basically-- this
is the first phase of Google
products when they launch.
They go in alpha,
and then there's
the general availability.
This is the command
line where you
can use to basically
instantiate these instances.
If you notice,
there's a new flag.
For those of you who are
familiar with the CLI,
that flag is a new
flag, which basically
lets you instantiate the VM.
The local NVDIMM size,
and you can set the size.
This is set for a 5.5
terabyte instance,
which basically gives
you the set of 6.7
terabyte total memory.
The instances are initially
available in Iowa.
This is US central.
But they're going to be
rolling out to other instances.
So if you want to
experiment with this today,
that's the zone that
you want to pick.
And then there's always
support from Intel and Google.
You can go to that website for
different programming models
if you're bringing your own
application to these instances
or you're trying with some
of the open source softwares
that we've been working on.
So that's the place to
go to get some support.
So now I want to talk to you
about some of the use cases
that we've been running
on this technology.
There's a lot of use cases
and different partners
that we have that have been
talked about during our launch.
And the collateral is
available for you to go review.
I would actually encourage
you to go and take
a look if you are thinking
about your own application
and redoing it in the
Google Cloud environment.
But here, I just want to
focus on a couple of use cases
that we have experimented in
the Google Cloud environment
and we've enabled in the
Google Cloud environment.
We've had access to these
instances for a couple months
now, so we've been running
different applications.
One of them has
been a Spark SQL use
case, which our teams have been
running in the Google Cloud
environment.
If you look at the
architecture and how
we've modified the
architecture for our Spark SQL,
we've actually
created that OEP cache
that's sitting between your
storage, your Google network
storage, and your compute.
And the way that
works is when you
get a query from your compute
into the IO, first time,
it goes to the IO, all the
way, all the IO latencies.
When you get the query, it's
then stored into the OEP cache.
So for the next iteration,
basically you're
going to be going right into
the Optane persistent memory.
So you're basically
reverting the year you're not
seeing the latency of the IO.
So that's how this is
getting the performance.
And if you look at the
experiment that we've done,
the performance is
actually showing around
4x better performance.
This is not the final picture.
We're still working
on some optimizations.
So we're expecting
to this number
to grow even at two times
what you are seeing here.
But basically, what I
wanted to emphasize here
is that with that package, with
the OEP package in Spark SQL,
you can basically get up to
8x performance improvement
from your queries.
What I wanted to highlight,
this is for a case
where your data is really big.
It's a big data set.
It doesn't fit in your DRAM.
It fits in the cache.
I mean, if you can implement
that same OEP on a DRAM,
the data wouldn't fit on it.
It would fit on
the Optane memory.
On the other end of
the spectrum of cases
for Spark is a data
set that is small,
that doesn't really
require as much memory.
For those cases, you
still have the advantage
of the cost savings that you do
because your per gigabyte price
of Optane versus DRAM is lower
in Google Cloud environment.
So across the
spectrum, you can see
there are different value
propositions for the memory.
This is one side
of the spectrum,
and the other side
is the cost saving.
And then one more
note, so this package,
the OAP package is
now open source.
It's available on GitHub.
The address is down
there on this slide.
If you want to download it and
experiment with it, feel free.
So it's there.
And then another use case
that we've been looking at
is a similar use case.
It's with Hadoop HBase.
Same thing.
So we have introduced
this bucket cache
between the storage
and the compute.
When you get a client
request from HBase client,
it basically goes--
if you can follow
that number one,
that's the flow of
your client requests.
It's going into the
network storage.
And then the next
time around, when
you make a request
from data, it's
actually going to be
in the bucket cache.
So very similar to
the Spark use case,
it's just for a
different application.
And then if you
look at that, that's
actually around 33x
better performance.
Again, this is the case
where your data does not
fit in a bucket cache
that's won on a DRAM,
versus when your data actually
fits into Optane memory.
So 33x for a better
performance, and then
on the other end
of the spectrum,
you still have the cost
saving benefit for the memory.
So again, this is going
to be open source.
I think that's the--
you can go to that link
at the bottom of the
slide and get the package.
So basically, these are some
of the-- some of the use cases,
like I said, there are multiple
many different other use cases
that we've been working on.
We're going to be
bringing those,
enabling those in the
Google Cloud environment.
We're also working
with different ISVs.
You saw that on the slide there.
ISVs who are taking
our optimizations
and putting them inside
their application.
And they're going to be
available through those
as we roll this
product out and as we
roll the partnerships out.
I think that's it for me.
Now I invite Andy to talk more
about the programming model.
ANDY RUDOFF: Thank you.
All right, thank you.
So we heard from Kristie that
there's this new Optane DC
persistent memory.
We heard from Shideh that
it's available on GCP.
And so I'm here to talk about if
it's on GCP, how do you use it?
Especially if
you're a developer,
you want to develop,
say, a nice cloud
application that takes advantage
of Intel Optane DC persisten
memory.
So I'm a software engineer.
And I can prove it because
they told me to dress up,
and this is what I wore.
So I'm really going to
talk to you about software.
The first thing that a software
engineer would have to decide
is, well, how do I
want to use this stuff?
And really, there's kind of
two broad categories here.
Do you want to use
it as volatile?
It is persistent
memory, but maybe you
don't care that it's persistent.
You just want to use
it for its capacity.
And so on the left side,
I've sort of showed you.
You have this choice.
If you decide just to use
this for its capacity,
you can do the lowest
impact to your application.
You can use memory mode,
which Kristie explained,
just makes the system memory
look like it's huge, right?
Your application
is not modified.
In fact, the OS
doesn't even need
modifications for memory mode.
It's completely
transparent to software.
OK, so that's one way to use it.
But if you want to do a little
better job on where data gets
placed, instead of
hardware deciding
what gets placed into DRAM and
what gets placed into Optane
memory, if you want an
application to decide
what gets placed into DRAM and
what gets placed on the Optane
media, you could use
the app direct mode.
But still, you don't care
on the left hand side
here that it's persistent.
It's called a volatile
app direct usage.
And actually, it's a growing
number of our use cases
use this method.
It's pretty easy
type of programming.
You just decide when
you allocate memory,
do I want to just
allocate from DRAM,
or do I want to allocate
from this other tier
that happens to be a
little slower than DRAM,
but it's a lot cheaper, right?
So you put a lot of
big data structures
into the Optane
media, and then you
put the really latency sensitive
hot data structures into DRAM.
On the right hand side
is the set of decisions
you make if you decide you
do care about persistence.
Maybe you want to use this
to store some in memory data
structure that is persistent.
It's there even if the
machine gets rebooted
or even if it loses power.
So again, you have kind
of two choices to make.
You can say, well, OK, I
want to use the persistence
but I don't want to
modify my application.
For that, we just have
the normal storage APIs.
It looks like a very
fast SSD, right?
The world's fastest SSD.
You just use the normal file
APIs that you're used to using.
They work.
They just happen to be
mind numbingly fast.
On the other hand, if you want
to squeeze every bit of value
that you can out of
the Optane media,
then you modify
your application.
And this is what I'm
showing on the right here.
You modify your
application to go ahead
and map this persistent memory
right into the application.
And then you get to
use loads and stores,
just like you do with DRAM.
So this thing on the right
here, it's the highest lift.
It's the most change that you
might make to an application,
but it's also the most value
that you can squeeze out
of the Optane media.
So when I started this
project a long time ago,
I knew that we would
need a programming
model to expose all the things
that I just told you about.
We formed a working
group in SNIA,
which is the Storage Networking
Industry Association.
It's essentially
a standards body.
And we got a bunch of
companies to come and join us
in the working group.
That was about
five years ago now,
and there's over 50 companies
in this working group
now, a lot of them that you
would recognize as operating
systems vendors and as ISVs.
And what we came up
with is this model.
And I've updated the
model a little bit
to use the term
app direct, which
is what Intel calls the
persistent memory that we
used in this model.
And you can see at
the bottom here,
I'm showing all the persistent
memory installed in the system.
Some of it might be
in that memory mode
that I mentioned before.
That's transparent to
software, so I don't
have to talk about it anymore.
The rest of it is
persistent, and you
can see we've added drivers
to the operating systems.
This is all true today
in Linux, and Windows,
and other operating systems.
I'll give you a
list in a minute.
And that driver exposes things
through this middle path
here as storage.
This is what I was telling you.
Applications can use
this programming model
without being modified.
They just think they're
talking to a really fast SSD.
But that's not the cool part.
The cool part is what
happens on the right hand
side of this diagram.
On the right hand
side of this diagram,
an application opens up a file
on a persistent memory of where
a file system and maps it in.
And you get this
far right blue arrow
that I'm showing here,
where an application has
mapped the persistent
memory directly
into its address space.
This means-- just
think about this.
An application does
a load instruction,
and it gets a value
off persistence
without any kernel code running.
Right?
There's no context switching.
There's no IO.
There's no interrupts,
no kernel code runs.
One instruction means
that you're fetching
from persistence, right?
That's pretty cool.
So, that all sounds
great, but it
does come with some challenges.
I don't want to make
it sound like it's just
the easiest thing in the world.
For example, if you put a data
structure in persistent memory,
you want it to be
something you can
get to after the machine crashes
if you have a crash or a power
failure.
And so it needs
to be consistent.
Now file systems do this
all the time, right?
If you're making
changes to a file system
and you lose power,
when you come back,
the file system has a
journal or something
that makes it consistent.
But programmers are not used to
doing this with data structures
that they just create in memory.
So that's kind of a new kind
of programming, consistency
with the face of failure.
What you really want are some
sort of ways of transactionally
updating your data, right?
And how about keeping track
of which persistent memory
you've allocated and which
you haven't yet allocated?
Again, that's a little trickier
than it is with normal DRAM
because it has to be
a persistent heap.
And so what you want
is a persistent memory
aware allocator to
help you with that.
Also, there are some algorithms
that are different in DRAM
than they are with
persistent memory.
What's the fastest
way of copying bytes
to persistent memory?
Well, we have different
instructions in Intel
that we've gone through,
and benchmarked,
and done measurements
on to figure out
what's the best way of doing
a lot of these operations.
So you want these
tuned libraries,
so that you don't have to
reinvent this all the time.
And then finally, when
you're programming
in your favorite
language-- for example,
you're writing a web based
application in JavaScript,
you want something
that gives you access
to persistent memory in
a way that makes sense
to a JavaScript programmer.
Right?
You don't want to be going
through some weird API
to call some C routine that
doesn't sound like JavaScript
at all, right?
You want it to be idiomatic.
You want it to make sense.
If you're writing in C,
it should look like C.
If you're writing C++,
it should look like C++.
If you're writing in Java,
it should look like Java.
So we want language bindings.
So y'all know what
I'm leading up to.
We took all of these things,
all of these requirements,
and we decided
that we could build
a attuned vendor neutral--
not just for this product,
but for any persistent memory
product--
vendor [INAUDIBLE]
set of libraries
to make persistent memory
programming easier.
Those libraries are called the
Persistent Memory Development
Kit or PMDK.
There's the URL
up there, pmem.io.
And the slide has a lot
of information on it.
But all of this
information is on pmem.io.
You can go find it.
You can see where the libraries
fit into that architecture
that I said before on the right.
See where the application is
now getting direct load store
access?
I'm not adding another
software layer.
I'm pulling in algorithms,
just what you need, right?
We call it shrink to fit.
Pull in just the amount
of software that you need.
You need transactions, pull in
the library for transactions.
You need something to look like
a JavaScript key value store,
just pull in that library.
And so I've shown
you on the slide what
several of the libraries are.
There are some low
level ones that
hide instructions from you.
They abstract away some
of those hardware details.
There are some
libraries in the middle
that handle transactions.
That's pretty
tricky programming.
So we get a lot of
use out of that.
And then we've built
on top of these a lot
of language bindings,
like I'm showing you.
C, C++, there's some
experimental Python bindings.
There's some Java bindings
we've been working on.
And like I said, there's even
some JavaScript bindings, which
are so new, they didn't
make it on this slide.
So this gives you a general idea
of what the Persistent Memory
Development Kit is.
In the ecosystem, like I say,
we created this SNIA working
group.
We had a lot of the operating
system vendors there.
So everything that
I've been talking about
is available upstream
in Linux already.
I'm showing you the
Linux kernel version
that we recommend
up there, 4.19.
There are two file
systems in Linux
that are persistent
memory aware--
ext4 and XFS are both already
persistent memory aware.
In Windows Server 2019,
all these changes went in.
And the file system that's
persistent memory aware
there is NTFS.
VMware, vSphere 6.7
and later also supports
persistent memory.
So everything that I just said
is true in a VMware guest,
right?
Including a program--
and just think about what
this takes to make it work.
A program running in a
virtualized guest does a load,
and it thinks it's talking
to persistent memory.
And it is because VMware
actually put all the plumbing
in so that it's actually
talking directly
to the hardware
inside the guest.
That's pretty cool.
There's the common
distros RHEL and SLES.
I put up there Ubuntu.
Java has some pretty exciting
changes coming in the upcoming
JDK release and so on.
And what else I
put on this slide
is I just thought
I'd show you what
does it look like when you
put all these pieces together?
So we have a proof of concept
that we did with Cassandra.
And you can see it here.
At the bottom, it starts with
exposing the persistent memory
using the persistent
memory aware file system
that I mentioned before.
You can see we used PMDK
here to first abstract away
the hardware details and then
provide some transactions.
On top of that, we
have the Java bindings.
The low level persistence
library for Java is there.
And then we made a
persistent memory
aware version of Cassandra.
So what's interesting about this
picture is the app at the top
has not been modified.
The app is just talking
to Cassandra the way
it always has.
But Cassandra and below knows
about persistent memory.
And this is really
a common pattern
that we've been seeing
when we modify applications
for persistent memory.
The knowledge that there's
persistent memory in the system
only goes so far up the
stack, and then at some point,
everything above is unmodified.
It just thinks it's
operating as usual.
So it kind of shows you.
So did I modify the app?
Well, some people would say no
because the app in my picture
hasn't changed.
Some people will say yes
because the app is Cassandra.
So decide for yourself.
But you can see the knowledge
of persistent memory only goes
so far up the stack.
[MUSIC PLAYING]